KEEP THE SEAT WARM.
I AM MORE INGRAHAM.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
NOT WHAT, MITCH?
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
IT IS TIME TO CELEBRATE MITCH
McCONNELL FOR SECURING A NINTH
TERM AS SENATE GOP LEADER.
>> I HOPE YOU ARE READY FOR YOUR
BIG BIRTHDAY SURPRISE BECAUSE
HERE IT COMES.
>> OH!
>> Laura: MAYBE NOT.
NEWT GINGRICH APPEARING LAST
NIGHT LATE INTO THE SENIOR
SENATOR FROM KENTUCKY FOR
FAILING TO RALLY THE GOP TROOPS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
>> I THINK MITCH McCONNELL
MORE THAN ANY SINGLE PERSON COST
US CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
EFFECT IS MITCH McCONNELL
MONTH A MITCH McCONNELL PACK
AND THEN RAISES THE MONEY AS
THOUGH HE IS GOING TO FIGHT FOR
CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
HE IS FIGHTING FOR MITCH
McCONNELL.
NOT FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, RICH IS
CORRECT AND HIS ASSESSMENT WAS
CONFIRMED ONE McCONNELL SHARED
HIS THEORY ABOUT WHY REPUBLICANS
SUFFERED THIS DISAPPOINTING
LOSSES.
>> WE UNDERPERFORMED AMONG
INDEPENDENTS AND MODERATES
BECAUSE THEIR IMPRESSION OF THE
PEOPLE IN OUR PARTY LEADERSHIP
ROLES IS CHAOS, NEGATIVITY,
EXCESSIVE ATTACKS.
AND IT FRIGHTENED INDEPENDENT
AND MODERATE.
VOTERS.
>> Laura: SOME ONE PLEASE
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW EXACTLY
McCONNELL'S ASSESSMENT IS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT PELOSI OR
SCHUBERT WOULD SAY ABOUT THE
GOP?
>> NON-MAGA REPUBLICANS WILL
JOIN THE.
>> IF THEY CONTINUE TO EMBRACE
MAGA, THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE.
THEY ARE NOT AT THIS EXTREME
ELECTION DENYING NASTY DIVISIVE
THREATENING VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: IT MUST BE PRETTY COOL
FOR SCHUMER AND ALL OF THE
LIBERALS TO SEE THE GOP'S PARTY
LEADERSHIP USE DEMOCRATIC
TALKING POINTS TO LAMBASTE
CONSERVE THIS.
OF COURSE, THE FOCUS OF
McCONNELL'S IYER IS NOT THE
BUSH CHENEY ROMNEY WING OF THE
BODY.
THE FOCUS IS THE POPULIST
MOVEMENT THAT REJECTS THAT.
LET'S FACE IT.
CHUCK -- OWE MITCH A HECK OF A
LOT.
IT CAN REPUBLICANS LED BY
McCONNELL MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS TO CLAIM A
BIPARTISAN VICTORY FOR THAT
IDIOTIC INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
IT WAS THE PASS FOR ADAM'S
CLIMATE CHANGE SPENT DRAMA.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE SENATORS
WHO HELPED DEMOCRATS PASS A GUN
CONTROL BILL.
HOW IS IT THAT DEMOCRATS RARELY
BREAK RANKS ON BIG BILLS BUT
REPUBLICANS ALWAYS SEEM TO.
BUT I GUESS THAT WAS YESTERDAY.
I DON'T WANT TO DWELL ON THE
PAST.
NOW REPUBLICANS WANT RESULTS.
AND HE WANT INSPIRING
LEADERSHIP.
A BLUEPRINT FOR THE FUTURE THAT
IS ARTICULATED AND REFLECTED OF
THE VIEWS OF A MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING FOR FIGHTERS
WHO FIGHT AS HARD AS THE LEFT,
ALWAYS UNITED UNITED AGAINST THE
OPPOSITIONS AGENDA.
WE ARE GOING TO BE HOLD EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HOW THE
REPUBLICANS FACE THESE FOUR
MAJOR CHALLENGES.
FIRST IMMIGRATION AMNESTY.
NEARLY FIVE MILLER PEOPLE HAVE
ENTERED THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
SINCE BIDEN WAS SWORN IN.
AND THAT IS NOT EVEN INCLUDING
THE COUNTLESS, A WAYS THAT THEY
WERE NOT ABLE -- EVEN ABLE TO
APPREHEND.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING
STARTED.
AND NOW THAT THE ELECTION IS
OVER, IT IS NOT SURPRISING IN
THE SLIGHTEST THAT THEY ARE
CONSTANT FAST TRACK TRACK
IMMIGRATION AMNESTY OUT WITH A
NOVEL THEORY.
>> WE HAVE TO PUBLISH AND THAT
NOT PRODUCING ITS -- ON ITS OWN
WITH THE SAME LEVEL THAT IT USED
TO.
THE ONLY QUAKE WHERE DID HAVE A
GREAT FUTURE IN AMERICA IS IF WE
WELCOME AND EMBRACE IMMIGRANTS,
THE DREAMERS, AND ALL OF THEM
BECAUSE OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
HELP THE DREAMERS, A PATH TO
SOLUTION -- CITIZENSHIP.
>> Laura: HOWEVER MANY.
TYPICAL PICKUP BY THE WAY.
AS AMERICANS ARE SUFFERING AND
OUR KIDS ARE STILL DEALING WITH
THE BRAIN DRAIN FROM COVID
LOCKDOWNS.
DEMOCRATS ARE MOST RIGHT ABOUT
HELPING THOSE WHO GAME THE
SYSTEM TO GET HERE.
AMNESTY DOES NOT WANT TO DO
ANYTHING EXCEPT ACT AS A MAGNET
TO ATTRACT MORE MIGRANTS.
BUT IF THAT IS EVEN POSSIBLE AND
YES IT IS POSSIBLE.
BY THE AS HE ALLUDED TO AND HE
SAID HOWEVER MANY MILLION ARE
HERE, IT IS NOT 11 MILLION.
IT IS MORE LIKE 2,530,000,000.
>> WE SHOULD ALL SHARE THE
SIMCOE AND THAT IS TO TAKE
11 MILLION PEOPLE OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AND SECURE OUR BORDERS
AND MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
NATION OF OPPORTUNITY AND
FREEDOM.
>> I UNDERSTAND COMPANY AS OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM HAS TO BE
TOUGH.
IT ALSO HAS TO BE PRACTICAL.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WILL GET
LEGAL STATUS.
>> THAT WAS FROM THE PRIOR
BATTLES ON IMMIGRATION.
AND YOU HEAR IT WAS 11 MILLION
BACK IN 2009.
THESE ARE EFFORTS THAT DIVIDED
THE PARTY AND ENRAGE THE PARTY'S
BASE AND ULTIMATELY THEY WENT
DOWN IN FLAMES.
2007, 2009, 2013.
THE VOTERS NOW NEED TO MAKE IT
CLEAR HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT THIS.
IF WE EVEN GET A HINT AND I'M
TALK ABOUT A HINT THAT
McCONNELL PLANS TO WORK WITH
SCHUMER TO RAM SOME KIND OF
AMNESTY THROUGH WHICH BRINGS US
TO THE NEXT GOP BIG BATTLE,
ABORTION.
IF SCHUMER AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT IT
WILLING POPULATION, SHOULD THEY
BE PROMOTING MORE CHILDREN?
YEAH.
BUT INSTEAD, THEY JUST WANT TO
CODIFY ROE.
REMEMBER, THE LEFT BEING PICKED
AS A WOMAN, WELL, THAT IS MORE
OF A DISEASE THAN A BLESSING.
>> LISTEN.
WOMEN ARE GETTING PREGNANT EVERY
DAY IN AMERICA AND THIS IS A
REAL ISSUE AND WE NEED TO ACT
WITH A SENSE OF HASTE ABOUT WHAT
IS AT PLAY, WHAT IS AT STAKE.
>> Laura: IF REPUBLICANS
SQUANDER THE LEGAL VICTORY OVER
THE ABOMINATION ROW, THEN SHAME
ON THEM.
THIS WOULD DEMORALIZE THE BASE
TERRIBLY IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO I ASKED WHERE IS MITCH ON
THIS?
EVEN BIDEN DOES NOT THINK THE
LEFT CAN PULL IT OFF.
>> President Biden: I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ENOUGH VOTES TO
CODIFY UNLESS SOMETHING HAPPENS
UNUSUAL IN THAT HOUSE.
I THINK WE WILL GET VERY CLOSE
IN THE HOUSE.
I DON'T THING IT WILL BE VERY
CLOSE.
>> Laura: ANOTHER CRUCIAL ISSUE
IS OUR THIRD BATTLE, THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
BUT APPARENTLY IT IS A TAXPAYER
MONEY FOREVER.
THAT U.S. HAS ALREADY SPENT
NEARLY $30 BILLION ON EIGHT TO
UKRAINE AND OTHER BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS REQUESTING
37 BILLION MORE AMERICANS JUST
CAN'T AFFORD TO BE DRAGGED INTO
A FULL-SCALE WAR WITH RUSSIA AND
NOT JUST FOR PHYSICAL REASONS.
TWO PEOPLE WERE KILLED
YESTERDAY, AFTER A STRUCK A
POLISH VILLAGE AND OF COURSE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
IMMEDIATELY SOUGHT TO WRAP UP
THE A QUESTION.
>> THE MORE THREATS THERE WILL
BE TO ANYONE IN THE REGION OF
RUSSIAN MISSILE.
>> FIRING MISSILES AT NATO
TERRITORY, THIS IS A MOTION -- A
RUSSIAN MISSILE ATTACK.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ESCALATION.
WE MUST EXPECT.
>> Laura: OF COURSE IT WAS
WRONG.
INTENTIONAL.
>> Reporter: OF A NATO COUNTRY
BY RUSSIA?
COULD HAVE LAUNCHED WORLD WAR
III.
THINK LEE POLAND WANTED TO KNOW
THE TRUTH BEFORE SPLITTING
ANYTHING AND ITS PRESIDENT SAYS
THE BLAST WAS LIKELY A UKRAINIAN
AIR DEFENSE MISSILE.
WITH THE U.S. DID TRY TO GET
ANSWERS FROM RISHIKA WELL, --
RUSSIA, WELL, THE COUNTERPART OF
MARK MILLEY WAS UNAVAILABLE.
>> RUSSIA DID NOT TAKE THE CALL.
>> MY STAFF WAS UNSUCCESSFUL.
THAT IS CORRECT.
>> Laura: THEY THINK SO LITTLE
OF US IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
MILLIE WAS NOT EVEN ABLE TO GET
THROUGH TO HIS RUSSIAN
COUNTERPART.
AMERICA COULD HAVE BEEN AT THE
BRINK OF WAR BECAUSE OF
UKRAINIAN MISTAKE.
MOST REPUBLICANS SEEM TO WANT TO
GIVE UKRAINE A BLANK CHECK.
WHEN THEY SHOULD BE PUSHING FOR
IMMEDIATE PEACE TALKS WITH
RUSSIA.
SO WHERE IS MITCH?
THEN THERE'S THE REPUBLICANS
MISGUIDED ATTEMPT TO THROW A
LIFELINE TO JOE MANCHIN.
IN A STATE THAT VOTED NEARLY 69%
FOR TRUMP IN 2020, SENATOR
MANCHIN STABBED HIS OWN
CONSTITUENTS IN THE BACK BY
SUPPORTING THAT CLIMATE BILL.
WHAT IS JUST AS BAD, THOUGH, IS
TO GET MENTION.
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THAT
DEMOCRATS PROMISED TO SPEED UP
APPROVALS FOR CERTAIN ENERGY
PERMITS.
IT WAS A TOTAL PITTANCE WHICH.
WE PREDICTED AND THE TIME.
AND DEMOCRATS BROKE THEIR
PROMISE.
NOW SOME REPUBLICANS ARE
PROPOSING TO RESCUE MANCHIN.
SOME OF THEM APPARENTLY SHOWED
APPETITE FOR A MATCHING DEAL.
THE HILL.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
MANCHIN ALREADY HAS A PRIMARY
CHALLENGER IN 2024 SO ALL
REPUBLICAN EFFORTS SHOULD MOVE
TOWARDS SUPPORTING THAT EFFORT
NOT PROPPING UP MENTION BACK.
THE ODDS ARE McCONNELL WILL DO
THE WRONG THING HERE.
CONNECTICUT THOSE ARE JUST A
HANDFUL OF THE BATTLES
REPUBLICANS WILL HAVE TO FACE
HUNDRED MITCH McCONNELL'S
LEADERSHIP.
AFTER LOSING THE SENATE AND
FAILING TO WIN THE HOUSE BY A
HUGE MARGIN, REPUBLICAN VOTERS
NEED A -- ASSURANCES THAT THE
MEN LEADING THE PARTY ARE
ACTUALLY ON THEIR SIDE.
McCONNELL McCONNELL'S 80
YEARS OLD.
HE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY OF THE
NEXT TWO YEARS TO CEMENT HIS
PLACE IN HISTORY AS ONE OF THE
STRONGEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE
LEADERS THE PARTY HAS EVER HAD.
BUT HE HAS ALREADY DONE ABLE TO
GOOD JOB ON JUDGES.
REMEMBER ROE VERSUS WADE WAS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE JUDGES
AT McCONNELL MAKE SURE THEY
WERE CONFIRMED IN THE CENTER.
AND HE PASSED A BUNCH OF
LEGISLATION IN THE TRUMP-ERA AS
WELL.
IF HE DOES NOT CEMENT HIS
POSITION IN HISTORY
ALTERNATIVELY, HE COULD SHUN THE
PUBLISHED MOVEMENT AND SPENT THE
NEXT FEW YEARS HELPING BIDEN,
HELPING SCHUMER, HELPING JOE
MANCHIN PERMIT THEIR AGENDA.
AND THAT WILL BE DONE ANOTHER
MISGUIDED PRESUMPTION THAT THIS
WILL HELP THE PARTY IN 2024.
THIS IS WHAT REPUBLICANS WANT.
AS LONG AS IT IS CALLED
BIPARTISAN, IT HAS TO BE GOOD.
>> MY MESSAGE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION, LET'S FIND SOME
THINGS BETWEEN THE 40-YARD LINES
THAT WE CAN AGREE ON AND DO
THEM.
>> MY MESSAGE TO THE SENATE
REPUBLICANS IS THIS.
WHERE US.
>> Laura: LET ME TELL YOU.
IF THIS IS McCONNELL'S MAIN
FOCUS, AND HE SHOULD EXPECT TO
BE THERE ON ELECTION NIGHT 2020
FOR WATCHING BIDEN AND SCHUMER
CELEBRATE UNDER THAT WIN.
EVEN THAT WE DON'T WITH MITCH
McCONNELL ON SOME KEY ISSUES,
WE CERTAINLY REALIZE THAT THE
ANGLE THAT HE HAS HIS SUPPORT
AMONG MOST OF THE REPUBLICANS IN
THE CENTER.
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH HIM AND
HIS TEAM TO ADVANCE A POSITIVE
AGENDA THAT WILL MAKE AMERICA
BETTER FOR WORKING CLASS
AMERICANS.
KNOCK IT THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
POPULIST CONSERVATIVE AGENDA.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
AND WE GOING TO BE WATCHING VERY